[Music]
ready to get this bread gamers
welcome to this episode of trash taste i
am monkeybrain
and here today i have two galaxy brains
you are correct on that
anything is to go by
except when it comes to chess when this
comes out
the only thing i'm competing at
apparently that's it everything else i'm
just
robin sticks together this goldfish
brain yeah man i just can't
i can't fathom anything else in my life
so what can i do i'm useless man
shout out to everyone who defended me
for my monkey brain um today
i want to talk about fellas i had a
thought last night i was like wow
i've got my life together
we all know we all know that's a lie no
one just thinks that
okay okay i've got my life more together
okay yeah
that's better and i was wondering i'm
like well i i've had like a
drastic life change from moving to japan
and that's not because of anything to do
with
right that's probably because of i think
the fact that someone's
holding me accountable yeah before if i
[ __ ] up a sponsor
it was on me yeah yeah right now there's
someone else involved
i was wondering because i'll explain
mine but did you you know when you guys
moved to japan
and you know maybe when you joined the
agency did your life change that much
did you like have a lifestyle change or
just same [ __ ] i think the biggest
change for me has been actually this
podcast
yeah well we have a specific day we come
in and film
and having something on my schedule has
just completely changed my entire weekly
schedule just because i have
i have one day that's always booked off
and have to like plan around that
instead of being like i'm gonna wake up
and i'm gonna feel like maybe i'll feel
like working on something today maybe
i'll just
feel like playing um ghost with sushi
tsushima i don't [ __ ] there's nothing
worse i feel than
like it being a monday morning right
it's a it's a fresh start to a new week
and you're like all right
let's see what i have to do this week
and you look on your calendar it's just
nothing this way
i'm just like what do i what do i do how
do i how do i do things now
especially especially after quarantine
you just wake up and you you don't even
know what day of the week it is
and weekends don't feel like weekends or
days or just
other days i don't know yeah most people
wake up being like oh yes it's a friday
it's the end of the week i just wake up
it's like it is morning
but youtubers every day is the same day
yeah yeah
when when when we everyone started
working from home and everyone was like
oh yes this is
such a refreshing change to my lifestyle
we're just like yeah
yeah welcome to your youtube live it's
fun when everyone's doing it and
everyone's in the same boat right then
when
you know everyone's doing their normal
life and working it's like it's hell
i mean that's how i felt though like
when we as as you said like we
started to be like all right every week
this day this time we're going to come
to the studio
right now and i'm just like oh this is
how normal people
feel it's quite liberating i drink
coffee with other people
i know it's great because you know when
i worked at the bbc
i worked for there for like two years um
like close
close to three years and i did not enjoy
it after a while but
after moving to youtube and being
freelance and just going by my own
schedule
i kind of missed the office environment
because yeah about like a year after
doing youtube i kind of realized
man if i don't like actively go out and
seek social interaction it just
doesn't it doesn't happen that's me like
three or four years to realize that
so why do i have no friends
unless they like drag me out yeah it's
weird i i kind of
yeah i kind of got that same thing
because i never had uh like a business
like
like a corporate uh experience right
like working in an office or whatever
so it's like extra exciting for me
because i'm just
because it is liberating because i've
always been even during school i've
always been one of those kids where it's
like
i couldn't study on my own like i had to
one of those yeah like i couldn't go
home and just sit in my room by myself
what do you mean one of those
like when they'd always be like y'all
want to study together i'm like no
oh no i was always like yes no i'm
exactly the same because i can't because
i know
that if i go home and i'm in my own room
then i'm not going to want to study
because no one's judging me for just
being like well i couldn't just like
play some games yeah but when i'm around
my friends i want to
talk to my friends no same here we never
when we
when there was always a group study
session we'd have in university i
remember we'd always have like the first
hour was
like nice and productive we'd start
going over problems and then it would
just
people would get bored and then we just
wanna watch this youtube video
yeah exactly that's always what would
happen
no i was a model asian son so i i
genuinely just like
hey do you want to go to the library and
do some study sessions
and then we put our headphones in and we
just study because if there's people
around that's a [ __ ] lie no no way
there's no way that
we and we all met up and we all studied
yeah it's like
what is why do you think i'm so galaxy
right i'll tell you the real mvp
which wasn't my lecturer but my actual
real lecturer was
shout out to those indian youtube
lectures that were always uploaded khan
academy
yeah what's that it's like if you did
maths or anything engineering yeah
there was always like this channel i
don't remember it might have been khan
academy or something like that where
they were just
upload the lectures that are shorter and
way more informative yeah
oh like kind of like cliff notes yeah
but like
somehow they explained it better in 10
minutes than the 2-hour lecture you went
to yeah
you go to your lecture you sit there for
an hour you wouldn't take any of this in
and then when you're revising you you
search up hey um x topic like
how do i use how do i do second order
integrate uh into
integra i can't even just integers
um uh and you there'd just be always
this is it was always an indian guy
doing the lectures i don't know why
they're just no maths man
they get it they get it man yeah i never
had anything like that i just i just
went
if you did any traditional route if you
did anything maths or engineering at
some point an indian man on the internet
would save you
like that's just how it is like that's
just because they i don't know why is
that maybe like only a uk thing
no no no because like it was like
americans too i think would use these
i think it's an engineering thing must
be an engineer yeah i never did
engineering
all the sciences yeah maybe yeah i never
had anything like that i mean i had like
indian lecturers like at school who were
like teaching me stuff and they were
usually like the best lecturers
but yeah there's so many in engineering
yeah i didn't have like any
youtube i wish i had like a youtube
channel that i could just [ __ ] go on
so i'm being like yes
solve all of my problems for me please
thank you so i don't have to go to
classes
i felt so p when i went to university
and it was in english and i was like
wait the internet's useful to the work
because like welsh internet like isn't
really a thing so anytime i'd want to
like
cheat i just couldn't because i couldn't
google any of this [ __ ] right
so i didn't know what i was looking up
yeah yeah yeah but yeah no man oh my god
my lifestyle university was so unhealthy
you guys really unhealthy oh definitely
is there any uni student who lives a
healthy life there was there was one guy
in my
my like uh year and he was like the the
peak form of
everything he like wouldn't drink he
went gym like every single day
and he always was the best but like had
what clubs was he part of because i
remember people who were like part of
the rowing club or
some kind of sports club would have
always the peak optimal lifestyle
and then there was like everyone else
who just like
yeah but that would usually be the one
where they would be walking down
you know the campus and people would
know that they're part of their club and
i would just be like look at this wanker
because they they wear like they're like
i'm in this club yeah yeah yeah yeah
look at this wanker wearing a polo shirt
he can afford a polo shirt
get out of here [ __ ] off i i feel like
because i went straight into youtube
from uni
yeah like you got the uni lifestyle i
kind of just
didn't change anything except for like
like i even like
i even like had an approach to youtube
making in uni like i was like
procrastinating my videos the way i was
doing with my lectures
right right where i would like not do
anything and then one day i would just
do
everything and then i'd be like wow what
a healthy what the hell
i was the opposite because i started
youtube when i started uni yeah
right so i kind of live like a double
life but usually
it's supposed to be the opposite where
it's like you should focus on
your studies right and like keep you
know maintained
and you know just because it's a hobby
right you can just procrastinate and
just do whatever now for me was the
complete opposite i was like all right
upload videos every day at this time get
it edited
get it done oh [ __ ] i have an assignment
in two days i think
everyone who is who's like seeing good
growth
does that though because i knew that i
should have put engineering first but i
didn't
no i put the youtube first yeah i don't
know how you managed to do daily uploads
while also going to university and still
passed
it's some of the easiest content that
i've ever made and like also
like compared to videos now i wouldn't
call my old videos
good editing because there was barely
any editing it was like
lots of cuts lots of zoom ins it's like
the easiest [ __ ] editing
put some background music in boom you
got a video right but yeah my computer
because
i really struggle with that because
obviously the upload speed in australia
is
[ __ ] horrendous like do you want to
connect yeah the internet like
the download was fine we had like 20
down right we're just like
not bad not bad right but you know what
our upload speed was like 0.1
pretty close like 0.3 oh my god oh god
so
uploading a like 500 meg video file
yeah which is like nothing right yeah
would take me like
eight hours jesus so what i would have
to do
is i would go to my classes i'd come
back
i would work on a video i'd edit it
until the night and then i would
upload it and then go to sleep and by
the time i got up in the morning usually
it was like
almost finished or it was done and it
would just be public by that point and i
would do that
every day for three years and
unsurprisingly
it was like i think it was like a month
before i decided to move to japan right
my computer just exploded like
physically like i was sitting there i
was editing i remember i was editing a
nekopara episode right that i was doing
and then one day just went boom it's
nekopara
that's nekopara like it's just it just
explodes like the cpu just exploded
and there's smoke coming up and
everything i'm like oh my this house is
going to go down like
this house is gonna catch on get out mom
this fire starts yeah this is this is
how like house fire starts
and yeah so we got rid of it and i open
up i remember i opened up the computer
and my cpu was just
gone it was disintegrated it must have
been constantly on you must have never
constantly on it was constantly on and
yeah and the computer was just like nah
can't do it anymore man wait did did you
live at home when you're at university
yeah oh [ __ ] that's been such a
different experience yeah yeah because i
i never got the experience of like
living in like a dorm right because i
like
having roommates i moved out at 18. and
i just turned 18
and i've pretty much lived alone or like
not with my parents since then
yeah i moved out after uni sounds like a
fun idea until it's really not after
about two months of living with other
people
yeah you realize man i really hate
people they're like well
you don't get a say in who you're put
within at least british university
and uh yeah sometimes you get put with
people you're like i hate this
i was put with like the rugby team
basically right and they were like
destroying everything constantly and
yeah i remember one time
i had like a pan specifically for
putting oven pizzas on right right
and he was like can i borrow it and i
was like well you know he's like
seven foot ten built like a brick [ __ ]
house i was like
sure it was like a it was like a one
pound tray from little right
i was like yeah sure anyway i go in the
kitchen at night to go and get like a
beverage
and i see my pizza tray and there's just
a carcass of a whole chicken
a whole chicken was cooked on my pizza
tray and he just left it
and i was like there's no way i can get
this [ __ ] off it's like charred on
yeah it's not even worth saving the tray
i'm like you didn't borrow it you just
liberated it you just took it from me
and destroyed it
i just couldn't believe it i was like my
mom's going to be furious
at that one pound friendship furious
how do i explain this to mother i just
yeah
i don't know i i hear stories of your
people living in like dogs
there was always one person who was like
the most disgusting person
like you you would you would be made to
believe by by your mum that you're a
[ __ ] slob when you go to university
oh yeah and like
you need to wash your dishes you need to
do this but then you'd meet that one guy
and you don't know how he like
functioned his entire life he would just
we had this one guy in our dorm who
would
just take everything take all the
utilities and you know any like spare
plate knives and forks and he just like
would leave it in his room and just
wouldn't wash it so
we would often get times where we were
just looking for like i would be looking
for my plates and lives and forks
and i like had to ask him and one time i
remember looking for
i think i think it was like a wine glass
or something yeah
and he found it in his underwear drawer
and i was just like you know what just
just keep going
i don't want it anymore god how how did
you how did you even
how does that even end up in that
underwear drawer that's so disgusting
yeah what the [ __ ] dude
i have so many horrible stories from
that like that period
and some of the [ __ ] they used to do to
each other like it wasn't even hazing
right it was just them being dicks like
like i remember
they didn't like this one guy in my dorm
because he was kind of pompous
he was like from south uh england and he
had a very posh accent and he was
very very like oh you're you're too poor
to talk to me yeah immediately sounds
like a wanker yeah
he was he was like an [ __ ] right like
and he would like
unironically call people peasants like i
call people
like is that how is that where you got
it from that's where i got it from
because i thought
i thought it was so funny that he called
people peasants and he used to think
that like i was laughing
at the people he was laughing at right
but i actually find it so funny that
we're in the year 2000 and he's using
the word peasant as an insult
so he would call these rugby players to
their face like
peasants and he's not like big but they
knew they shouldn't punch him right yeah
so what they would do multiple times
was like piss on all of his stuff in the
middle of the night
and like leave it outside yeah so they
pissed in all of his like
uh kitchen stuff yeah and so he went to
go and cook
the next day right and he was like where
are my pans connor and i'm like
look outside my cousins have taken
i told them they shouldn't do it but you
know what can i do
but i did not stop them i was like i'm
like oh oh no guys i was that dying
university who was like
not hated and not like be like in their
group but i was just like they liked me
enough where they would like tell me the
[ __ ] they were doing but yeah
yeah they wouldn't [ __ ] with you yeah
yeah they didn't [ __ ] with me um
they would always like meet in my
bedroom for talk it was weird
so they would piss on all this stuff
they got completely ruined and they
bullied the [ __ ] out of this kid it was
awful well i mean yeah i
don't blame them like [ __ ] okay if a
dude came up to me and was like hello
peasant i'd [ __ ] give him a hand
i'd be like let's see how these peasant
hands feel [ __ ]
oh my god dude they were so they were
crazy man i can't believe the [ __ ] yeah
that
i hear stories like that i mean like i i
hear from like people like you guys and
just
friends at uni who used to live in the
uni dorms and i'm just like
why why did you sign up for this [ __ ]
like it sounds it sounds horrible
because it sounded it sounds like when
you're moving into university it's like
oh it's
it's a party every day that sounds
amazing and then
you realize that people are just
[ __ ] most of the time
yeah i just had like a flashback to a
horrible thing that happened what's
going on so
it was halloween right and we had a
little rivalry with the bungalow next
door we were in bungalows by the way
right
rivalry with another bungalow that was
full of dudes what would you do to get
back at them
like what would you do like just send a
message right
i don't know like whatever you're
thinking it's not as disgusting as what
they did
just tell us what you did yeah what did
you do so it was halloween and i was
outside having a
can of lager right i was watching them
do it and i was like i'm not gonna
be involved in this but i'm gonna watch
this yeah of course one of them decided
it would be a good idea to like take a
ship through their mailbox
so they did that and then they
retaliated
by getting that [ __ ] putting it in a
halloween a
pumpkin sorry and throwing the pumpkin
at one of
my friend's windows and it just exploded
it was so disgusting so then they just
thought okay well they've this is all in
the same night by the way
and again i'm just watching all this
unfold
this is better than any anime i've ever
seen like because because they would
like ask you is it like you can actually
do this i'm like that's a great idea
that's great yeah go for it yeah
fantastic
yeah then they're like watch this and
then one of the rugby guys like i'm
gonna like
smash their door in as a joke i'm like
that's an amazing joke yeah that's so
funny and so they smashed his door down
front door to their their like bungalow
they smashed it down
as a joke yeah like just destroying that
just destroyed property
yeah it wasn't even theirs and then the
university obviously found out the next
day and was like
who did this and i and i was like i have
no idea
and uh they got they got so much does it
have
[Laughter]
[Music]
they're like literally monkeys just like
throwing [ __ ] around without my light
just flinging [ __ ] right basically these
guys were like all in the rugby squad in
in like the the biggest rivalry in wales
and rugby is like the big imagine like i
don't know which state is like the
biggest american football state right
yeah but imagine like the biggest
meatheads in america
yeah just in the same place like it's
like i mean we can just have that in
sydney as well
yeah disgusting [ __ ] is gonna happen and
yeah yeah i guess because i was just
like
they liked me enough it wasn't hell for
me yeah i mean they would still use my
[ __ ] all the time it was really nice
were you in like the really cheap dorms
oh i was in the ones that cost
70 bucks a month okay
i had like what would have been like a
psychiatric prisoner room
like it's like the bear but bear but
they gave us a mattress and i wish they
didn't
because i immediately when i got there i
pick up my mattress and it's
bright yellow the bottom of it and i'm
like oh god
and i remember i remember getting
homesick the first day i'm like mom i
can't do this this is disgusting
it was literally like a tiny room with a
shit-stained bed
that they'd obviously never changed no
it was obviously like university dorms
are basically just remodeled prison
cells
yeah yeah like i think i'd rather go to
jail connections
i think i'd rather go to jail at that
point because the bed that they they
gave us i remember thinking oh it's
probably going to be a single bed i
didn't know there was a size smaller
than a single guy
wait there is how do you hear that i saw
it because it was way smaller than the
single one you
you you'd like to sleep like this like
you
anything else and like my feet because
i'm like a fairly tall guy i'm not even
that tall
i'm six foot my feet was would always be
off the bed
that's how small my bed was just like
three pillows stitched together
so there's your mattress jesus christ
yeah
i'm glad i never experienced that i i
would just i would just bite the bullet
and just take the two-hour travel
between yeah
my uni and my house and i'd just be like
i'm in the comfort of my own i learned
some important life lessons university
though
right i learned like you gotta sometimes
you just gotta say
[ __ ] everyone else and put yourself
first sometimes
i mean i i i learned that afterwards
people will just [ __ ] take advantage
of you
oh yeah definitely yeah
like because there was only like one bus
that made it to
the campus on time like it was like half
an hour bus
it's only one bus and uh this line would
be
[ __ ] huge to get on this bus so if
you were late it was just whatever yeah
and i got to the point where i was just
like i'm going to be so late for my
lecture if i wait in this line i would
literally just like when people were
getting on the bus i would just walk to
the front of the line just
kidding i would literally just like act
as if i was on the bus i would just walk
up
awesome and then everyone would look at
me like the [ __ ] we can you can do that
i was like [ __ ] it i don't care that's
like that's like sacrilegious
in in england british yeah that is that
is like a cardinal and i would never do
that but i thought because they're all a
bunch of university students i'm like
[ __ ] you it's it's survival of the
fittest [ __ ]
we used to do that in high school where
like the because uh
do you guys have like middle school and
high school like seminar right now it's
all like 7th grade to 12th graders all
together
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so same in
australia and uh
you know every time like the school
finishes there'd always be like lines
for like different bus routes that would
like go in yeah yeah same time
and of course all the [ __ ] seventh
graders and eighth graders just like
get on they just [ __ ] start running
up and the 12th graders and the 11th
graders would just be like
out of the way [ __ ] the [ __ ] posted
these kids out of the way they couldn't
do anything but it was the most
liberating thing to do it was like
finally when i got to the 11th grade i
was like
i understand i have power now it's
[ __ ] awesome
learn the hierarchy yeah exactly step
down
i was a very anemic scream but this
god's anemic scream aside this video is
sponsored by
one punch man road to hero 2.0 one punch
man road to hero 2.0
is the officially licensed strategy card
rpg mobile game featuring the voice
acting and storyline from the hit anime
one punch man gotcha and grow your team
of heroes to overcome the threats to
your city while unleashing your epic
ultimates and show what it means
to be a hero for fun they also have
anime story lines and cutscenes there's
also idol rewards that you can play at
any time
anywhere at your fingertips so because
it's a mobile game you can play it
literally anywhere play when you're
pooping in a mailbox
you can play it while pooping in an
airplane anywhere you're pooping you
play one punch man
just play while you're pooping what why
are you pooping now
there's over 50 plus heroes to collect
from the anime such as boros fabuki
and genos there's also epic season 2
content on the way trying to develop
characters while unleashing their epic
ultimates as you create the strongest
team in formation to rise in the ranks
of the hero association leaderboards
there's also multiple modes such as the
story mode the tournament pvp mode the
road to be strong it's a roguelike
gameplay element
the adventure puzzle mode the mission
dispatch the guild bosses
extreme trials tower climbing there's
too many to count you will never not be
bored especially while you're pooping
and you can also use code zero2hero for
all these freebies you can see on screen
right now
is that 120 character shots gone yeah i
think there's also two hours of strength
crystals as well
you're kidding me and there's also two
hours of character xp times four
i heard there's also diamonds times and
then jerry there's also more it's two
hours of cash times for needless to say
you are being spoiled if you use this
code and don't worry to our
international audience because this game
is also available in
english german french spanish portuguese
russian and turkish that's seven
languages
that's a waterline that's more than i
can count so be a hero for fun and go
and download the game today using the
link in the description down below and
don't forget to use our code zero to
hero now back to the video
jeffery horror university stories then
that weren't dorms anything
at all that was like [ __ ] up another
friend that like i had
like other than like one being you know
one of my friends being like a drug
dealer like i'm like not really like
wow yeah i mean i don't really have to
go into detail on that obviously but
you just see so much [ __ ] in you know
like you know your story about like you
know throwing the poop at the bungalow
like i don't have anything that crazy
no that was that was really common for
us like
that was really common did you say yeah
like
what [ __ ] universities did you go
just walking around campus and i'm just
like
i didn't know i could ever see [ __ ] in a
location like this
yeah yeah you see vomit and [ __ ] where
they're like
understand the vomit right because like
we had like a whole bunch of like pubs
and restaurants like within the campus
right so obviously
you get a little bit crazy as you do as
a uni student and you you know throw up
a little bit but i'm just like
why is there like poop on this sidewalk
it's like we're not actually i i'm now
that you guys are mentioning it
i'm remembering so much poop that i've
just like
blocked out my memory like i'm like this
is bigger than an
apple it's not an animal it's clearly
not an animal like this is a human poop
i know what human works they are an
animal
but it's like it's like it's not even
like it's not even like a kangaroo or
like a big animal like this
this clearly came out of a human i think
i think it must have been pretty bad at
my university because they had like a
row of porta-potties that would just pop
up on friday through sunday yeah where
where all the clubs were so clearly
people must have been
[ __ ] enough and pissing that they
were like we gotta sort this out
pooping everywhere but there's this i
just keep remembering there's so much
poop where there shouldn't be like
i remember one day are like most amazing
podcasters
there's one time when uh came home came
home from one light out and there was i
was in the common room and it just
smelled like some someone had died there
it smelled like an animal or died maybe
it was a dog or something
start looking around like searching for
where where this smell is coming from
i'm like playing the game of where's
wally
just just with this smell right i'm like
searching everything
it was around christmas time and and so
i searched behind there was there was i
searched behind the christmas tree
because it was
like coming from the christmas tree so i
i look behind
and there's just this turd like sitting
where there should be presents and
my first thought is surely this can't be
a turd
right and like you said it's not it's
not like a dog turd it's like a full-on
it's like it's clearly a human being
right like yeah yeah it's
it's not like rabbit poop or something
it's like a big full-on turd my first
thought is
surely there's no way this is a turd
this is in your house
huh in your house uh yeah in my dorms
what in my dorms
so it was it wasn't a house we lived in
like a shared shared dormitory of like
200 people so we have like a common area
so so i get this [ __ ] stick right i
start
poking it just think maybe it's
something else other than the turn maybe
it's like a
maybe it's like a toy chocolate
and and the stick just sinks in i'm like
oh oh this is a [ __ ] turd oh
i am smelling [ __ ] right now how did
this get here
because it was in the common room
because it was pretty late but people
come here people come in the common room
pretty often
and i i was just like i was just
thinking there must be a story behind
this how how did this turd appear here
i never found out oh my god that's such
a wish all i remember was coming coming
in the next day in the morning and it
was just
magically gone and i was like i feel
sorry for the person who had to
clean that turd up man see i just hear
[ __ ] like that i'm just like
yeah but don't you me like you get some
[ __ ] stories that you're like
you're never gonna forget oh yeah of
course but like i like hearing it from
other people i don't want to like go
through the [ __ ] trauma of like
experiencing a lovely christmas morning
with a turd right like
i don't need that in my life it doesn't
affect him he's like i'm going to match
my room
yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm out that's
someone's story
this is right okay this is why people on
the comments are like why does khan have
so many stories because i just say yes
to the dumbest [ __ ] thinking like okay
if this goes horribly wrong at least i
get a banger of a story out of it right
probably so i'm just like yes i'll do
that thing that's probably very
questionable yeah
like sure let's go there let's do this
thing because i'm like
i'm gonna get a banger of a story out of
this i love that so i just forget a lot
of stuff sometimes i go through my life
yeah
i get like flashbacks when sometimes
we're talking yeah [ __ ]
like speaking of poop i remember i
remember that story no because like
going back to lifestyle in university i
remember had the most
unhealthy lifestyle you could possibly
oh yeah like i i
i shouldn't a human body shouldn't be
able to do that many all-nighters
yeah and somehow i'm i had a diet that
just consisted of mostly red bull
how many how many red bulls would you
drink a day and coffee i would
um i would drink at least at least three
cans of red bull a day
yeah and like two cups of coffee yes
yeah that sounds about right but like on
on like some all nighters when i had an
assignment that was never ever done
until the night before i had to put in
my assignment because who the [ __ ]
actually does
does the simon sweeps before remember
one one one night i had
i think it was like 10 cans of red bull
something like that heart rate must have
been like
yeah oh no it was it was insane and
don't do this do not do this this is a
cautionary tale
and the deadline was at 8am and i
finished it at 7am
and i remember i remember thinking yes i
can finally submit it
so i submitted it and i laid down my bed
and i could not stop shaking
i just i was just like
and i remember that was the exact moment
that i remember thinking
man i need to sort my [ __ ] wife out
like i'm gonna die
yeah dude because i i hit like [ __ ] and
i was drinking like
10 red not terrible i was like at least
like three monster energies a day
yeah on top of coffee and then also
eating like domino's pizza like two
times a week oh yeah i i kind of had a
similar story where like
a lot of the times like because i wasn't
living in the the dorms
yeah i would just sleep over at the yeah
in the room that i was like working on
right so like we i remember like i had
like a programming assignment i had to
do yeah and
it was of course it was a teamwork job
right and that
never goes well in uni there's always
that one [ __ ] who never appears to any
of the [ __ ] assignments
and i was just like and it was just like
me and like a friend and we're just
waiting for this third person
like where the [ __ ] is he he's like the
best of programming here like we can't
we can't do it just with the two of us
of course the dude never showed up so
it's just like great
well if the thing's due in like what
three hours it's like five in the
morning right now let's just store the
dominoes
so [ __ ] called up the dominoes we
order like [ __ ] like
seven pizzas or something we're just
like hey everybody if you're if you're
at the uni right now just come to this
room
just order like seven dominoes just come
in here and we'll just eat dominoes
and the next morning i remember the
professor came in and it's just like
seven empty boxes of pizzas and there's
like eight of us just like all sprawled
out of the crowds
with pizza hangovers and uh yeah that
was the best story i have
obviously not as uh interesting as a
poop story but uh
where's the poop i'm not invested i mean
we all smell when did someone [ __ ]
themselves
i mean we definitely all smelt like [ __ ]
the next day but that's about it
i'm sure i have like way more stories i
can think of but like i just
like none of them are coming to me right
away yeah but i just forget a lot of
them
dude i didn't realize that like i got
like super chubby during
university i know ghana's like connor
you never look chubby but dude
connor connor swears to me that he was
chubby when i first met him and i just
have completely blanked out this memory
of mood and put this image on screen
this was like
two years ago though i look back at old
photos right how about you
and i'm like man this boy's face is
around right
i never thought i was chubby right no
but i didn't think yeah
at the time yeah i think because it was
just the way i'm built like i don't look
that choppy
but i remember like a year ago like i
saw
like an image like someone's taking a
photo of me and it was like from the
side right yeah i just saw like my
stomach
like hanging over a little bit and i'm
like what the [ __ ]
when did that happen yeah and you're
like what and then then you start
realizing oh [ __ ] i'm chubby like i'm
actually chubby
it's so weird because i had such [ __ ]
diet and just like lifestyle choices
in uni but i was so [ __ ] like you you
guys like when you first met me i was
[ __ ] emaciated
you were so scared everybody everybody
always says that i was so [ __ ] you
are so
skinny to put in comparison right like
all throughout high school
i haven't really like grown in height
since high school yeah i'm hovering
around like 180 centimeters right
a little under six foot in high school i
think i never broke 60 kilograms
jesus christ what are you now then i am
75 now oh [ __ ]
yeah i get
and i was just going ham and i didn't
realize that oh
metabolism is a thing yeah yeah i i
realized that during university
obviously
i'd been going taking advantage of my
body weight
oh yeah yeah then pretty much last year
i just went ham on myself and like just
cut out everything kind of energy drinks
went gym like five days a week and
lost like 10 kilograms yeah because i
remember back then i
didn't know if i had a bigger tolerance
in alcohol or caffeine
but it always it was like i was drinking
equally much of both
equally destroying my body with as much
[ __ ] that i was eating yeah
yeah i was probably eating in food alone
like 3000 calories
probably consuming like 2 000 calories
at least an alcohol
and that's not even like the monster
energy drinks that were probably like a
thousand calories plus all that
so i was going like ham on my body
because you know when you're like 19
you're like yeah bro
i don't gain weight i've never been
through yeah i'm not going to get
anything i mean that's the thing and
like i had like an insane
diet when i was in high school yeah yeah
as well and it's not just like the [ __ ]
i was eating but just
how much of it i was eating like lunch
like lunch
you know like high school lunches for
like a lot of people is like you know
maybe like a sandwich or you know
like a hot dog maybe or something like
that dude i used to have
10 slices of bread i do i could do that
and just like devour that before the
noon hit
i was just like i just got to school i'm
feeling a little bit hungry i just eat
like three sandwiches
and i and i was still skinny as [ __ ]
people like how like
jealous how how violent are your shits
because that's the only way you're
getting rid of it i think it's that
asian blood man because i've
consistently
like i've i've been about the same
weights my entire adult life
i'm jealous yeah so jealous well i don't
know i think my body just
when i eat when i like start getting
weight my body just shuts off and it's
just like i don't want any food
like i'm just never hungry so it's i
don't know it's never been
a big deal [ __ ] superpower i mean i'm
okay with it now because i went from
dangerously skinny to just normal weight
yeah but obviously people have like
stuck around on my channel and have seen
me in that like emaciated state i just
like joey's going really fat
i'm like no i just went back to normal
that's all that happened i'm not
fat we all know youtube comments like to
nitpicks yeah exactly
with like university life did you go do
you guys feel the same way
you know my parents always told me you
know when you go to university that's
where you grow up that's
that's you know that's how that's that's
what they said
yeah yeah because that's where you're
like treated as an adult
right right with responsibility and
stuff but anyone who's still in
university
is such a warped experience of what
adult life is like
yeah you know what i mean it's i yeah
because i guess university is kind of
like the ramp
to being an adult the way i saw it like
there was people there who
left university who i'm like you you
should not be living alone
you cannot take care of yourself and
then there's other people who i'm like
yeah you know they'd be fine you know
like i feel i feel like if you can't
take care of yourself at uni you're
really gonna have a hard time taking
yourself after
uni as well we've definitely met those
people
like half people i lived with were like
incapable like one of them was like a
serial gambler and like lost all his
money
and like one of my friends was the same
yeah he one one time he
won 10k 10k for uni students
which is insane basically a millionaire
yeah yeah yeah you're basically a
[ __ ] millionaire and everyone's like
no [ __ ] way you won that much he lost
it within two weeks
two weeks because he was so addicted to
gambling
it's it's [ __ ] insane oh gosh i asked
him so how how could you spend the money
you could have paid off your student
loans and everything yeah and i remember
him just saying oh because it just
didn't mean anything to me
because there was like a guy in
the house next to me the one that got
pooped in um
as you gentlemen know as we all know and
he was like
basically like a neo-nazi and he was
really [ __ ] weird
and he would always come over and bring
like two
40 year old women and and he was like
having threesomes with them both
and he would exclusively refer to them
as like sugar tits
like did he like time travel from the
50s
and he was like and i remember one time
because my friends
give me a sugar date so yeah he was like
he was literally like
my friend was telling me he was like
yeah it's really weird he was like
mixing chemicals in his room and i was
like
bro tell the [ __ ] university people
like
what do you mean he's mixing chemicals
in this room you're really you're really
doing a good job like selling on whales
yeah like this where'd you go again i
don't want to
name the university in case they get
really mad at me but
bristol university represents sydney uni
you can find out what university
it's all that hard it's somewhere out
there yeah he was always that guy
who was like you know when like someone
would talk about a fight they were like
well if i had my glock there it would be
over you know what i mean
and you're like what what do you mean
like come again it's just that those
guys are like yeah i know how to use gun
it's like yeah gum would fix that yeah
always and it's like he like talks about
guns too much
he he brought up like mine camp like
uncomfortable
like an uncomfortable amount of time
right like i remember
my favorite piece of literature he was
like
i remember one time it's like his excuse
for not doing an
assignment was because he was too
in-depth into reading about nazi history
and how interesting it was and like
that's always like a double-edged sword
like a red flag yeah it's like are you
interested in or like
interesting yeah are you like this
sounds like an episode of peep shows
luckily never had to deal with it my
friend did yeah
apparently one time uh he he
my friend who was telling me all this
had borrowed something from the the
neo-nazi character
yeah and um he it was in his room and
his
his room was locked and so this guy
didn't want to wait 30 minutes to do it
so he just took all the bolts off his
door with like a screwdriver set and
just removed the door and went in
and never gave him his like door back
like the stuff
but like two weeks before the university
came and fixed it the dude had no door
and he had like a gaming pc and
everything like that you just had no
door
and the front door to this bungalow was
always left open
there's like there's there's taking you
know like utensils
yeah and then there's taking a door he
like took the like the door
like with all the like the what the [ __ ]
handle all the hinges he just took it
off
and just removed the door to like the
side like it's like a caveman with a
stone entrance
like um i need my my keys or something
whatever it was and you just
did like this dude was insane he was the
kind of guy who like when you're around
him for five minutes you're like i don't
want to be around you anymore
you've said too many uncomfortable
things in five minutes and when he
brought his two
40 year old woman girlfriends around
like they're disgusting get them out of
my house
his sugar tits yeah he's so gross
i was like 20 like cleaning my dishes
like what the [ __ ] is happening
so like how did you transition from
university life to like your working
youtube
schedule adult life the real adult life
or whatever we want to call it
so i think for me i'd finish university
i broke it to my parents that i didn't
want to do a masters
yeah they were like fair enough you
clearly didn't want to do a bachelor's
which i did i passed it with a good
grade so that's fine yeah and i was like
you know what
i go to london a lot why not [ __ ]
move to london yeah on a whim
i i've moved to japan on the win move
went there and just uh
that was kind of it really yeah because
when you met sydney for the first time
we had you already decided that you were
going to london
yeah yeah i knew pretty much like i was
i wanted like about halfway through my
last year of university i was like
i don't like wales anymore yeah i really
really like london
right so i'm going to move to london and
i know the prices were like insane
yeah managed to find a roommate to help
me split the costs and yeah and then
just kind of
went into it and it was really weird
because it was like i don't know just
doing the same [ __ ] in just
a different city i guess yeah but like
no one like teaches you about that [ __ ]
yeah
you just gotta do it and just hope for
the best you're like oh [ __ ] i have to
pay taxes how do i figure that out and
it's like oh [ __ ] okay i need to figure
this out
i have to check the mailbox yeah yeah
just so many things you have to like
figure out and hope that you're doing
right
yeah yeah i don't know like what was it
for you like because obviously you did
like a way bigger
like leap yeah because i mean i
i had like a gap year where
in in in between from in between
actually starting uh between graduating
from uni and actually starting my job at
the bbc
yeah and that was when i kind of went
like that was when i went all out on
youtube before i just completely
stopped yeah so the period before i
completely stopped i i like
spent a lot of time on youtube because i
had basically nothing else we were still
not making any money during that time
yeah i wasn't making any money oh [ __ ]
um it was just
because i had nothing else to do and i
was really enjoying it and
yeah because that was about what about
the time like potaku started and a lot
of a lot of new things
right right happily invested in it yeah
i was pretty heavily invested in that
and i remember i this was like such a
weird year for me because i would spend
my time like all over the world
um just in different places like i i
lived in china for a bit
yeah uh really yeah yeah
why huh um reasons i don't really want
to get into
but i i i was there for a bit and then i
was in thailand for a bit and most of
the time i was just working on youtube
videos
and by the time by the end i just i
wanted something stable i wanted a job i
thought i wanted a job at the bbc
right i thought wrong
and it was it was good for the first
year about the first year was it was a
good experience it was like yes this is
this is a nice break from university and
and just like doing youtube for a while
because
what i didn't realize is how hard
university life is compared to
of having a real job yeah like you you
guys don't know but
the [ __ ] the stress and [ __ ] you go
through in uni is like
ten times as much as anything you'll go
through oh yeah
yeah you've got like drama on top of
having to do like
10 assignments all at one time and yeah
yeah yeah yeah
because it's like if i fail one
assignment i am stuck here for the rest
of my life yeah like i i've been
stressed but never as stressed as i was
at university oh yeah
yeah yeah because they all were always i
don't know if it's the same for you guys
but in my university they always put
like all the deadlines
at the same time yeah yeah so it was
always like two months of like i'm
having a great time playing league of
legends 12 hours a day
got nothing to do and then boom november
hits you have eight [ __ ] assignments
two exams coming up yeah and four exams
on top of that two exams that you have
and you're like
holy [ __ ] it's constantly [ __ ] in
your pants yeah yeah i'm gonna
i'm gonna die i'm never gonna get out of
this yeah yeah but like i still had my
really unhealthy lifestyle that i had in
university
yeah like in my job at the bbc okay so
let me explain to you my sleep schedule
for the bbs oh i want to get it i was
just when i really wanted to go on okay
okay because my my sleep schedule was
disgusting
um because because at the time a lot of
my friends were online
and a lot of them unfortunately were in
north america right which
the best time to talk to them was either
like probably like really late for us
you know so
you just get used to staying up super
super late so
that was fine when i was in university
because it was easy to do all nighters
anyway
but when i was working at the bbc um i
had a nine-to-five job
so i'd need to get up i lived five
minutes away from my workplace
that was a good thing because if if i
didn't my sleep schedule would be even
worse than it already was
so i would stay up until about
um till about four a.m yeah every day
right it's pretty normal yeah
but i would wake up at eight so i'd have
i would have like
i would have four hours of sleep do you
do my nine to five month preparation
do my nine to five four hours of sleep
be [ __ ] dead for the entire day
um and then go back home at around five
six o'clock
have have a two hour nap and then that
was my sleep schedule
i never had one long sleep it was always
like intermittent
like i would i would have a maximum of
like three to four hours
at a time every night just like space
spaced out by like eight hours
yeah that was my sleep schedule for a
full year jesus i think
being friends with americans especially
in the uk because of how the time zones
work you're like five hours ahead you
end up like you're talking to them
you're having a good time and you're
like
yeah i can talk for an hour extra and
yeah it'd constantly like the hour extra
ads
yeah exactly yeah before you know it the
sun's rising and you're like
[ __ ] yeah i i mean schedule
oh yeah of course oh okay yeah like i
was the similar thing because like
as you said like a lot of my like
youtuber friends were in north america
or
not in australia essentially so i always
had to adjust to their time zones and
that was usually like three or four a.m
right but but at least i didn't have to
get up at like
8 a.m i would get up at like maybe 2 p.m
yeah that was like
if i got up if i got up before noon that
was weird for me
i'm just like that's this this isn't
right i can feel the morning sun
i felt the morning sun before i went to
bed
i don't know if you guys did this but i
would like just slowly
deteriorate my sleep schedule to go to
the point where i was going to bed at
like six
seven a.m yeah and then i would you know
wake up at like four p.m
yeah right um like i would do the thing
where i would
completely [ __ ] it and then i'm like i'm
gonna fix it today
and then i fix it and then i immediately
start just chipping away at it
it like offsets by an hour then an hour
turns yeah yeah
yeah two hours and it's three hours
you'll have that one night you and you
i'm sure you've had it where you're just
like
for some reason you stayed up until like
8 a.m yeah and you're like
[ __ ] there's no coming back for some
reason when it's when you step to 8 a.m
it's easier to keep on that
sleep schedule and keep on a healthy
sleep schedule right yeah it's so
it like i physically like i remember
last year it was
so hard for me to try and fix this like
i would try and stay up i would fail
and then i would try and wake up early
and i would fail so i was just in this
loop for like i remember like two months
i was trying to [ __ ] fix this thing
and i could not do it and then when i
did
i had to fly to america and then come
back and just immediately fight yeah
like so it was like i couldn't win and i
know this sounds so stupid like just
wake up early connor yeah like
lolita just wake up early just do it but
it's like for some reason when you're a
youtuber and you have no
responsibilities
it's like impossible to fix this just
put an alarm on your phone yeah it takes
so much willpower
to fix your sleep schedule oh yeah it's
it's it's really difficult when you
don't have any responsibilities or a
schedule to stick right or people
relying on you apart from your viewers
like this is probably the first year
that i think almost every day i've
gotten up at like a normal human time
yeah cause i remember when i first moved
here you were still waking up pretty
late
oh yeah when i was like when i was first
living here like at my previous place
before rocky moved here with me
i was getting up at yeah like you know
maybe like
12 1 p.m yeah and i'm just like yeah
this is
reasonable time yeah i went to bed like
5 a.m last night so i got my sleep
yeah i think being on this time zone
like americans are always asleep
when i want to like do [ __ ] so it's i
just go to bed and then they're all
awake
i don't feel any pressure to stay up
here there's like no reason unless i'm
out
yeah cause i remember you talking before
about how you would record videos at
2am yeah i'd record because i woke up at
like six i don't want to do anything
when i wake up 6 p.m by the way i would
wake up at like 6 00 p.m
in wales right before i moved to japan
because i was i was kind of like
i don't know i was pretty depressed i
was like i hated it yes i was just like
i just wanted to move to japan
i was just stuck in this shitty bedroom
that i didn't like yeah
my brother's bedroom wasn't even mine i
hated it it was in the attic room
no no no no no no [ __ ] it i wish it was
actually more space
i hated this room i hated being in wales
i'm sorry parents i love you but
they know i hate living in wales i hated
it so much i had no friends really
yeah and so i i would just stay up until
like
9 10 a.m yeah and then i would go to bed
yeah wake up at 6 p.m
and then i couldn't do anything as well
because everything was closed right so i
just
i was just a perpetual cycle everything
opens and then closes
while you're literally literally
everything would open and close while i
sleep and then when i wanted to eat
anything like i couldn't
i had to like preemptively go to the
shop to buy things that i think i would
want later
yeah for dinner i think like i had a
similar problem like that in japan but i
think it's because i was relying too
much on the convenience of
the 24 yeah yeah because like i would
get up but you know i'd stay up till
maybe like 3 a.m and i'd be like i'm a
bit hungry
everywhere else in the world you're
pretty much [ __ ] like you have to look
in your fridge oh america
i mean you know you could do like
delivering stuff like that but it's no
you know
in my case like i would get out of the
house literally walk 20 meters
to the 7-eleven that was like across the
road from my house yeah and just grab
something and come back i'm like
well yeah of course i'm going to stay up
because there's no time limit
with food especially or anything like
that right yeah but
yeah recording at 2 am though like
that's that's insane
how would your yeah 2 am foreign how did
your neighbors find it
[ __ ] them dude dude i would be like in
bed at like
like what was it ok this is why my
signature wasn't too bad like 4am
and i would hear [ __ ] peppa pig
[ __ ] blasting through my walk
it's like like muffled
i'm like shut the [ __ ] up it's 4 00 am
so i didn't give a [ __ ] i was like [ __ ]
they were still [ __ ] to me so i was
like you know what you should have just
blasted
back dmx through the wall like peppa pig
version
like i have like a similar experience to
the first house i lived in london
because
if you live in london you could live
you're gonna live in a shared house
that's just the way it is in london so
we had
paper thin walls right and i would live
next i lived next to this couple
who just like would not stop having sex
and it was just not good on them good on
them get on them but it wasn't it wasn't
like the
discreet sex that like they were loud
and it wasn't even like sexy loud like
the girl just sounded like a dying dog
okay that's the kind of like the kind of
that's kind of like the noise i had to
live with but i think they would
i think they did that because they got
annoyed at me recording podcasts and
videos so they would feel like i'll show
him they would choose to have sex
right like whenever i start recording
like like
it was it was coincidentally every time
i started recording a video i just hear
these [ __ ] moans
on on the on on the wall um and i would
have to wait like a good
like sometimes it was an hour i like i
don't know how what couple constantly
has sex for an hour every time i swear
they were like
taking
but yeah i think they were just having
like shouting contests because they were
just annoyed at me
recording videos and podcasts yeah some
episodes
you can kind of hear like we had we had
to blank out my audio because there's
just like moans in the background
release the uncensored footage they were
like the moment they're like they
they just look they're just like you
putting their ear to the wall in the
moment they hear
warning they're just like all right
let's go let's go right now come on put
your pants out
let's go honey start moaning honey
i do and it wasn't even the videos that
i was loudest for it's like sometimes i
would record like
voiceover that was like full-on battle
cries yeah
it would literally be like and i can
shout loud oh yeah
it would be like full-on battle cries in
my [ __ ] house at like
1am because i was i was the only time i
was awake i'm like ready
anywhere else in the world nothing like
a murder was happening yeah they were
here
they didn't give a [ __ ] in london they
were like oh it's you know we live in
south
south south london
i would god dude that yeah i did not
like my neighbors they were they were
[ __ ] and the one time they stole my
package as well
so [ __ ] them [ __ ] you for stealing my
package
yeah i see the only experience i've ever
had of like living or having neighbors
to worry about is
here in japan but it's never been
anything like that i mean i had that
like really one
recently that one really passive
aggressive woman
she gave me like a good it's not the one
time either that's like the third or
fourth letter she sent me
can you explain the whole story i'm
interesting so i i don't know the
timeline so basically i don't even
remember when the first one was but
basically i came home once
and like the in in japan i don't know if
it's in other
countries as well but at least in
japan's and apartments they have like a
mailbox downstairs on the first floor
and they also have like a little like
male entry thing i think that's on the
door i think
i think i don't know but basically i
came home and i was about to open the
door and i
saw like a piece of paper sticking out
so i'm like oh okay maybe it must be a
flyer or something you missed a package
yeah i missed a package or something i
pulled it out and i opened it and it's
this really
it was really creepy because it was like
to nobody
it was clearly typed out and there was
just it was just in english
and i read it i'm like this sounds
google translated and i read it and it's
the woman down
it's a guy or a woman now says i don't
even know who it is because when you
first moved to an apartment in japan
it's customary to like go to everybody
every room that's adjacent
yeah so the two rooms to the left and
right of you and the person above and
below you if there are any
and go and like basically say like hey i
just moved in here you know
if you ever need anything i'm in this
room kind of right the p two people to
the sides of me
[ __ ] great i love i love both my
neighbors person the woman at the top
super nice barely talk to her but the
woman at the bottom
she didn't even come to the door like i
rung the doorbell i clearly
heard her running up to the door to look
in the peephole you should put your
thumb on the people yeah
and then and i guarantee the moment that
she like looked at the peephole and like
saw a gaijin she's like oh hell no
i'm not going out there dude are you
kidding me so immediately i was like oh
okay i have that kind of neighbor right
well
whatever yeah and uh and then yeah so i
immediately knew
it didn't say when this letter it didn't
say it was who it was
but man like she must have not thought
this through because in the letter she
said
i always hear you guys stomping around
so i'm like well then clearly you live
behind me
you're not even hiding it now and she's
like yeah um
your stomping is so loud in the night uh
that i am getting uh
insomnia and i'm just like okay
i mean sorry like like you must hate me
then in my previous place because i was
up till like [ __ ] four a.m
like i'm living a normal [ __ ] life in
this place
um yeah and she kept sending me it and
i'm just like oh my god what am i gonna
do with this woman so
the moment she sent this like recent
letter like a couple of weeks ago i was
like you know what
i'm gonna [ __ ] show this woman
because i'm getting [ __ ] annoyed
because she threatened to like
burn down her apartment so i unscrewed
the hinges in her door
i broke down her door and threw poop at
it
i shut in her mailbox
honestly honestly would have got him
actually yeah
no so uh so i was like i'm gonna show
this woman so cause like clearly
by writing by typing not even like
handwriting by typing out a clearly
google translated letter to me
she obviously thinks like oh these
[ __ ] dumbass foreigners don't know
anything and
there's this like mentality of like
xenophobic like japanese people usually
very senile
who think that they can get their way
because they're a senile japanese
person and we're just a dumb foreigner
who doesn't know the rules
so i'm just like all right i'll show
them so i wrote a handwritten letter
in japanese in the most like keigo as
[ __ ] like
the most businessman the most polite
japanese that you could ever see right
like i might as well have like written a
[ __ ] like invitation letter like a
resume to the
kingdom right and so i wrote it down and
i basically said like
i'm sorry but we got to do it because i
work at you know sometimes late at night
and like we're not trying to be noisy or
whatever and it's like
and i basically said at the bottom i was
like rather than you like taking it to
like the housing company and trying to
threaten me
maybe we should talk like you know face
to face
which is basically the most passive
aggressive way of saying come at me
[ __ ]
it's like [ __ ] meet me outside like
come at me been to your house you don't
stomp no we don't look like pretty at
all
and it was like really rude as well like
she wrote down being like your footsteps
sound like uh you are dropping an iron
ball
onto the ground i saw the google
translation
what the [ __ ] like it's not like we're
[ __ ] neanderthals and just like
stomping around in our apartments right
here [ __ ] around tick tock dance
yeah so i sent that so i went down i put
it in her
letterbox surprise surprise she hasn't
complained since
she never took it to the housing company
because i guaranteed the moment she read
that letter she was like
oh [ __ ] he ain't a gaijin
[Laughter]
as well the one to the uh so i'm on the
end so which is great because yeah where
i film is also
on the end that is just nothing like
yeah yeah so it's great so i
i'm i'm you know i can be loud during
the day or whatever but so
the neighbors to the the right of me
weren't in and so
we went to go to the neighbors below and
mainly do you remember that you remember
this story right
when we went to say hi to the neighbors
below oh yeah because you went with him
didn't you
no you weren't there no you went there
okay so i went to say
hi to them below and so i was with uh
someone from geeks plus and the housing
agent person
right and they press the like
button the thing that goes
they pressed it and you know they start
speaking in japanese and they start
having a conversation
and slowly i see like the two japanese
women with me looking slowly more and
more like displeased yeah
what's being said right and like if i
remember correctly what was roughly
translated was like oh
my husband doesn't let me talk to
foreigners without him there
or something and i was like and the
housing company
put woman was like i'm so sorry i'm so
sorry
don't worry about it this is it's just
old or whatever
i was like oh great what a warm welcome
like my husband won't let me talk to
foreigners like jesus
like what am i gonna do yeah i'm like
mike wazowski at the door like what are
they saying
that's being said so what are they gonna
do
[ __ ] in my mailbox they're like i hear
they [ __ ] through mailbox
pumpkins these dirty foreigners break my
daughter
i'd laugh if they were just actually
talking the mad as [ __ ] yeah and then it
translates
like yeah she just uh doesn't yeah
i wouldn't be surprised i mean i wish i
you know knew
i could understand japanese level i can
now maybe i wouldn't yeah just like i
wish death upon it
is like she's feeling unwell
it was probably something like that yeah
it's probably something like that yeah
but i mean i i bump into my other
neighbors all the time and they're
pretty chill they always say hi to me
yeah my neighbors next to me are like
this like really old couple who
used to live in l.a so their english is
actually like productive
as well and like and that's good because
like aki isn't like the most proficient
in japanese right yeah
but they obviously know that and so
every time they like meet on it was
really weird because like i was walking
to my local supermarket and my neighbor
like walked past and it was really weird
because i was expecting you know like a
very
like traditional japanese like oh yeah
kind of thing
no instead she was like how you going
like a really like weirdly like
australian british accent as well
and i'm like i thought you said you
lived in l.a
that doesn't sound very los angeles like
yeah yeah and it was just i was just
like oh oh
hi i guess oh because i was fully
expecting to do like the whole bow thing
right but she was just like
sup some some old people are real
[ __ ] nice here and they love speaking
to you
yeah and then other times like they they
just they want you dead
yeah yeah i mean i guess that's old
people everywhere with foreigners right
there so no
that's not good but i think japan takes
it to like a whole other level it's just
it seems like one one extreme or the
other yeah it's hard for me to say i
mean i'm
white and grew up in a white place so i
don't know i mean in england nobody
like nobody talks to each other or like
no like acknowledges
generally talking is frowned upon
i remember actually the first time i
went to america i was i was in new york
and this was the very first like my very
first experience in america because i've
like
pretty much only been in england and
basically europe and thailand
um so i remember i was standing in the
lift my hotel
and this american there was there was
one other person in the left
and she asked me so how how are you
doing today are you having a good day
and me as a british person i [ __ ]
freeze up
like i don't know how to act like i'm
like
are you are you picking a fight with me
what the [ __ ] going on here
what do you want for me are you trying
to sell something because in england you
don't talk to each other you just
every everyone stands there in awkward
silence and doesn't acknowledge each
other
and we go about our day i i had the same
thing in like canada on a bus
i was like 17 maybe i was on a bus and
the guy like said
like great weather i decided i'm not
doing it yeah great weather
today and i just ignored him because
i didn't think he was talking to me and
then he was like not much of a talker
right
and then i like did like you know how
like uh l stares at uh
light yeah i was like
you talking to me
[Laughter]
because she talks over to me and the
first thing i did was check if there was
someone behind you
i was like yeah in the uk you're it's
just not a thing you don't you're
definitely
i i remember thinking like oh
uh yeah yeah yes
like what do you
you don't know what to do i know better
now yeah i had the i had the craziest
[ __ ] like elevators i didn't even
know if i'm allowed to [ __ ] talk
about this one
i mean i mean it's it's it's not the
extreme situation it's what the guy
said he's got a [ __ ] in a pumpkin
no so it was my first time in l.a ever
and it was
anime expo obviously because what else
would you go to l.a yeah um
and i was in the hotel uh you know uh
aki was there
no i validated a store in l.a now it's
always l.a
but you know my japanese side is always
like if you're just in the elevator by
yourself
and you can just be like rowdy and you
know have fun and talk to your friends
and everybody right but the moment
someone you don't know comes in
you've got to like behave right you've
got to like quiet down because you don't
want to like
it can be islam right i've told you guys
the story
yeah so it was me aki and like a few
other people we knew
and we were going down the elevator
obviously just chatting it up whatever
elevator like stops halfway door opens
and this like black guy walks in
don't know him right so immediately i
was like oh [ __ ] someone's
you know coming into the other side
let's stop clowning around yeah let's
stop climbing around you know like we
don't want to inconvenience him
he walks in really quietly door closes
starts going down and then he just goes
oh yeah everybody shuts up when the
edward walks in
i didn't know whether to say sorry or
like because if i said sorry then
like we would mean that but i couldn't
say anything like i couldn't even be
like so i was just like
eyes darting he's just being like what
am i supposed to say
so what are you supposed to say to that
in that situation and i was like man
america's [ __ ] terrifying like
i'm i'm taking the escalator from now on
i've never felt more complimented in my
life than when i went into an
elevator in l.a and there was like i
think there was a bunch of women uh
there was been like five or six of them
and they were like all like mid-40s
i don't know what they were doing and uh
they were just saying something and they
asked me a question and i just responded
and then when they heard my voice they
were like
oh damn where are you from
i was like yeah it's like oh i'm i'm
from i'm from the uk and they're like
what do you do and i was like i do have
a voice acting like
yeah yeah you are
i was like i was like oh no i am in
danger
but i was so i was so flattered that
like gave me like the confidence boost i
needed that day i was like hell yeah i'm
ready for this panel yeah but
when when you were like in america with
a british accent yeah yeah yeah
with with any accent that's not american
yeah yeah and i think it's like a deep
voice as well
yeah yeah cause i get that all the time
too like every time i go to a starbucks
or whatever and i order something like i
remember i remember went to a style box
once in like vegas
and uh and i said i don't remember what
i [ __ ] ordered i was like can i get a
mocha frappuccino or whatever the girl's
like
see that again and i'm like i thought
she didn't hear me right so i was like
yeah can i can i get a mocha frappuccino
and she's like
your accent's so nice i'm gonna have to
hear that one more time
i think i would die inside i'm just like
there's people like [ __ ] staring at
me i'm just like i just want a [ __ ]
marble for a vagina just give it to me
please so now every time i go to a
starbucks i'm so afraid of that so i
just
don't know what are the mocha
frappuccinos yeah i was like no i just
do my best to do like an american accent
and they never [ __ ] questioned
americano please
yeah i'm just like can i get can i get a
latte and they're just like yeah okay
which one do you want give it uh
do you ever play up your accent more in
the us
[ __ ] turn that [ __ ] on like a hundred
yeah sometimes i do if i want to get out
of a situation
yeah i just start [ __ ] talking like
bogan australian sometimes just so like
where it gets to the point where they
clearly don't understand what the [ __ ]
i'm saying and i'm just like all right
i'm out i'm out here do that do you ever
turn up your british accent
um i mean i i go like full
[ __ ] downton abbey in america
sometimes because they [ __ ] eat it up
dude
like if i really want them to be nice to
me yeah like and like the the waiter
yeah
yeah i want good service oh thank you so
much that's amazing wow
wow thank you this food is delicious you
did a great job
oh my gosh and they're just like oh
my god like such like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
though
i just it's fun it's fun man people are
so nice use it to your advantage man
i guess so yeah and then and then i
remember the americans would ask me
they're like
do you guys see american accents the way
that we see british accents and i'm like
no not at all not at all oh i think like
attractive yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
they were like because they were i did i
remember one time i the way i explained
it so i was like
if there's an american on public
transport everyone knows
everyone knows they know the loudest
yeah they know they know they hate it
yeah because we're so like like
everything we consume obviously is like
american media we just use so much
american stuff so we're so desensitized
to american media
and obviously to americans it's like oh
it's a flavor of british
i thought she's interesting very
international i think it's also because
we've been to america so often now
four like conventions because i remember
back in high school but i think even
just general british people aren't like
impressed by americans
accents i mean i remember back in
university whenever someone had an
american accent they would definitely
stand
out maybe less so now because there's
more i think there's more americans
coming over to england to study here
yeah we had that like one
american exchange student in our high
school and
everybody [ __ ] loved it they were
like yeah like keep talking
yeah yeah many things have changed i
don't know man at least in my my
university
i mean i definitely i mean we're all
used to it but i think god and i
definitely used to because we live with
an american
yeah right i'm definitely used to it now
yeah
before before then it was definitely i
do think it was
more exotic before i because i remember
like american accent sounding so
harsh yeah like you could clearly hear
like the the hard
r like i mean yo what is that
i can cancel the heart
because we don't pronounce the r's in
all of our words right so like when we
when we hear the r in like like the
sound right like i'm just like
oh oh god why stop please
i don't know hearing americans say
british swear words is like the most
disgusting yeah we've said this yeah we
talked about [ __ ]
like uh like in a previous podcast but
like hearing sometimes
sydney would say wanker oh my god
there are some british words that should
never be said that yeah yeah
wayne valencia i don't even want to hear
an american say belland
bell i mean we don't even say that in
australia no we have a bunch of british
ones you guys have australians
yeah but like oh my god the first time i
heard an american say wanker
i was like yeah i was like oh speaking
of wankers
the most the one that i hear sometimes
americans say that i'm like please don't
they're like [ __ ]
i'm like yeah
have you ever had any like you know
because you both have american american
gf's right
have you ever had any like weird thing
like cultural difference that you've
like stumbled across you're like why why
do you do this
i mean i i didn't have it with aki but
like
you know as i mentioned earlier like my
first couple of like youtube friends
were americans right yeah and before
then i didn't really have like
international friends like all of my
friends were just aussies yeah basically
um and so like when you speak a lot of
like especially in australian slang
right which is like pretty much a
different language in and of itself
in your head you're just like oh yeah
this is just a universal word that you
use
so i remember like saying a bunch of
slang to my like american youtuber
friends like uh i don't know if you guys
say like arvo
no that's australian that's definitely
australia it's too uncivilized
it's a peasant's language i'm ironically
peasant
yeah so like we say like you know
instead of like five in the afternoon we
say five in the other
you're just cutting out stuff that
doesn't need to be cut out yeah like
it's afternoon it's too long of a
workout
to say it's not that's normal that's got
more than four letters no thank you yeah
and so i said like so you know
obviously my american friends were like
you know what time is it in australia
right now and i'm just like oh it's like
three in the arbor and they're like
three in the arvo
what's an arvo and i'm like oh my god
they don't say
ava so i was like three in the
afternoon do you understand and they're
like oh yeah yeah yeah
do you understand do you understand are
you youtuber
it's been really funny seeing how like
when i first joined the internet like
the british accent was like praised and
now it's just meme to [ __ ]
yeah like everyone every tuesday tuesday
oh yeah
youtube it's because it's because i
think americans only thought that like
the the southern uh you know yeah the
posh yeah
then they realized that like 90 percent
of the uk sounds disgusting
like it actually does like my dad's from
liverpool
and when i like go to go there i i hate
this i hate to hear it they speak a
different language over there the the
more nor
i'm gonna i'm gonna insult the [ __ ]
north now because i love the north but
some of the accidents i
i i hate like some some of the the more
further north you go
the more i'm like up into scotland
the more i'm like man i i know we're
speaking the same language but for some
reason i cannot understand
what we're saying even though we're both
apparently speaking english right now
yeah
i remember we were watching a tv show
with aki and it was like dudes from
yorkshire yeah and i was
out and you me and you having no problem
understanding yeah yeah and aki was like
is there
subtitles i i can't understand what
they're saying
i showed her like monty python's holy
grail yeah and she was like i need to
put subtitles on yeah
she's like i i just like i literally
just don't understand what
his actions are yeah and she was like no
no it's because it's an old movie and
the audio is bad i'm like
it's got nothing to do with the i can
hear it fine
it's crazy but what one thing i will
never [ __ ] understand i'm sure a lot
of americans will like
understand this but like when you say to
an american what is like
the sexiest accent like what is like an
accent that you want like people to like
whisper into your ear
yeah for some reason australian accent
is always
like the top that's like and i'm just
like what the [ __ ] are you on about
australian accents are [ __ ]
disgusting
australian's like on like bottom three
it's like yeah it's like you're only
thinking australian actually because
you're thinking like chris hemsworth
right like
it's like yeah of course everyone wants
chris hemsworth to whisper into their
ears
of course but chris hemsworth is like
the .001 percent of australians
as as every british actor yeah right
anything like that and it's like it's
it's
like i think i saw like an article was
like the top three are like australian
british and irish people is pretty good
too
scottish is like i understand scottish
and uh irish yeah i think that's like
kind of cute i like scottish irish yeah
scottish and irish are really really
nice right but like
i hear like the majority of british
accents and the australian accent i'm
just like nah
i can't i i grew up in the north and
like i was surrounded by those accents
yeah yeah and that's why i get i get
mocked when i go back they're like
you're not
from here yeah you you definitely don't
sound like the area that you're not no
no and i don't know if
that evolved over the time it did if you
go back to my
my very first youtube video i sound like
someone
from the area that i grew up oh yeah
when i first met you you had like
quite a heavy like welsh accent yeah i
wasn't even wow she was like more
northern but like because the
the welsh accent sounds like this you
know
and i never sounded like that yeah but
everyone in my village talked like this
but you don't but you definitely didn't
sound like you do now no no i didn't i
sounded like more
just like general northern english yeah
yeah cause i've lost my accent quite a
bit people yeah
yeah when i look back at old videos i'm
like ew yeah yeah
because because i was strong because you
like really iron out your like
you enunciate a lot more yeah i think
that's it's just a youtuber accent right
where you have to
we have to like stop mumbling and start
paying attention to what you're saying
because
people from all different races are
going to be like listening to you yeah
because like because like the word
literally yeah i
in australia we say literally yeah that
sounds like yeah but i can't say
literally anymore i have to say
literally
i don't know why and my dad gave me so
much [ __ ] for it the last time i was
home he's like
what the [ __ ] did you say literally you
sound like a [ __ ] american man
i was like say literally like a true
aussie i'm like all right
thank you for your patriotism i got
accused on one of the comments they were
like
connor isn't from wales connor no one
i'm from where connor is no one speaks
like that that's right yeah
and like it just didn't cross their mind
that like your accent can evolve
yeah exactly i think there was a study
that was uh done in antarctica where
they like sent
you know when they go to the scientists
go yeah and they wanted to see from all
these european scientists like what
would happen to the accents
right over like the three-month period
and it would fight like normally they
would all
for some reason pick up one person's
accent the most right
generally start to talk the way they did
yeah and i think that's
how it is like it can quickly change
your accent if you're surrounded by
people who sound
and i think that's why like i've lost my
accent a lot of the times because i have
spent like just from what i do i've
spent more time with non-aussies
yeah i spend a lot of time in london and
then spend a ton of time in japan a ton
of time around america
yeah there's words like that i pick up
from like you know british english and
like right
right yeah it's just it kind of just
becomes like a conglomerate of just a
bunch of different languages
right it's it's just kind of a mixture
of like internet language as well pretty
much one of the international pretty
much yeah
i'm sure if i move back to england my
accent would like slowly develop slowly
back
uh slowly back into more of a bridge i
haven't noticed that though when i go
back to australia and i talk to like my
high school friends or whatever i just i
just immediately kick into like
australia
like i remember uh when i met uh robert
ninja
or ross yeah you know he's an aussie
right yeah yeah but he's
been living in america for so long that
his natural accent is just american now
yeah but i remember
the first time i met him at aex the
moment he heard my accent he was like
oh yeah man he's just [ __ ] like he
just completely changed to an aussie you
know it's just like
you could all you could talk like this
the entire time and i reckon like more
people would be like
into it yeah yeah that happened to me
when i went back to wales i definitely
like
regained some of my my my older accent
yeah i didn't like i don't like my old
accent i prefer this one
i like to like speak clearly and like
you know yeah like more concisely yeah
more of a voice acting accent yeah it's
more generalized and
allows me to say words easy
before i struggled with words so you
know
so then i'm curious how like since you
guys have moved to japan right
about like your lifestyle changes like i
think it's because doing youtube
here i feel is completely different to
doing youtube anywhere else
in the world yeah yeah i don't know if
it's because we have like an agency here
that keeps us in track
yeah because i'm my own worst enemy and
if i can be lazy i will be lazy
yeah yeah so having an agency has really
helped me like just
stay responsible you know and i don't
want to let them down
right right right not that i was letting
myself down anyway
i don't really don't want to [ __ ] up
because meleen will kill me
yeah and also having like
japanese class two times a week that i
have to be awake i have to be there by
nine so i have to be awake at like
7 30 to get there which i did this
morning yeah
this
like i basically have no choice but to
maintain like a healthy lifestyle
before coronavirus [ __ ] i was going gym
like five times a week i was so hyped
for that and now i don't care
yeah i know because i don't want to go
to a gym and [ __ ] have to run in a
mask right
it's just not yeah i mean you can't and
you can't even do it outside anymore
because it's like 35 [ __ ] degrees
yeah like 80
humidity i just like don't every time
i've been working out recently i'm like
it's just
[ __ ] i'm not i'm not doing a good job it
just feels bad where you would make
such good progress and then you have to
take it like two months off yeah and you
go back to the gym and you're
like i was getting so many gains bro my
arms were getting beautiful
yeah i mean we're all going to the gym
together and it it's just yeah it's it's
just sad now that
that's okay but overall other than that
i mean like
it's i don't know what exactly it is if
it's just the different time zone that's
forced me to
i can't talk to americans as much as i
used to yeah i
have to take care of myself i eat better
here just because there's more healthy
options
like the whole thing where you're like
you know why are people so thin in japan
it's just because the healthier food is
more readily available and you walk a
[ __ ] ton
yeah you really have to like search for
crap food here oh yeah i don't think you
do
you don't but like there's let's go to
the conbini and half the [ __ ] and that
will make you fat as [ __ ]
yes but it's just like whereas in the uk
it was like
you had to pay a lot and find the
healthy food it's like it's equally
distributed where it's like
you can have extremely healthy food and
right next to us the bad stuff and it's
like it's not a question of can i get it
it's do i want to get the healthiest
yeah it's it's not like in america where
like you know a mcdonald's is like
readily available five minutes down the
road
right you have to like [ __ ] look up
like you have to go deep on yelp to find
like a vegan restaurant i mean that's
i mean that's the tldr of why i think
people are thin in japan is you walk a
[ __ ] ton
and there's way healthier food yeah it's
just it's just a lifestyle thing where
people because you're surrounded by
people who have a much healthier
lifestyle
you kind of like you you kind of they
kind of guide you into having a more
healthy lifestyle
yeah because everyone else around you is
not eating like [ __ ] and not like yeah
sitting in the past like when i order a
domino's pizza and then joey's like yeah
i had a salad i'm like [ __ ] i mean
you think last night yeah yeah yeah i
had like a meal
last night dude matsuya's my favorite
place on earth
the best when i joined you wanna explain
matzia so there's like three
like beef bowls the big three the
basically the big the big three of like
beef bowls and just general like meat
and rice
yeah fast food chains so there's matsuya
yoshinoya
and oh my god what's the third one
everyone will everyone on like the vlog
channels be like go to yoshinoya like
no don't go to yoshinoya let me tell you
why matzia is the best straight away
first of all in the australia you have
to speak to people i don't like that
right
you have to like tell the person what
you want i'm not for that i like it when
the machine
takes my order and i give the the man
the ticket i don't say anything
yeah i just get my meal right right
right i love that first of all because
it's an english option as well
not that like you know everything should
have an english option i'm not here for
that i'm just saying that it's nice that
i don't have to worry
when i'm eating because sometimes in
japan you're just like [ __ ] man i just
want to order without having to [ __ ]
myself
like japan japan makes it like a lot of
places in japan make it very easy just
to not have human interaction
yeah which i appreciate which as a
british person
that's fan [ __ ] tastic what i hate
though
also as a british person in any
restaurant in japan if they don't have a
button
that calls the waiter to you you have to
call them yourself
and so in england the etiquette is that
you try to be as quiet as possible you
you like look for eye contact okay you
look far
like excuse me yeah yeah even the hand
hand is a risky move
oh yeah you even the hand you're kind of
making a scene there yeah yeah
it's kind of just it's like it's a lot
of this like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like you want the
bill it's like uh
okay and that's as much as that's as
much as you do to get a waiter's
attention
in japan you gotta shout out you gotta
shout out the top of your lungs
dude koreans are like laughing their ass
off right now they're like these
peasants
but the worst part is is that like me
and gone will go like i'll go like full
volume like sumacer
and the silence
they're like coming over the speed of
light i'm like what the [ __ ] i don't get
that
because like the other like last week we
went to like an izakaya afterwards
after we finished recording and because
it's the user guide that doesn't have
the button so yeah
conor mcgregor just like oh with this
[ __ ] again it's like so fulfilling
prophecy the moment you sit down right
it's like i know that it's okay to shout
publicly like to get their attention
yeah
like my body has been like crafted yeah
it's conditioned
yeah should never ever ever make any
public disturbance
it's the same in australia so like i
remember like the first couple of years
i lived here like i never did it
yeah i always just kind of just did this
like a lot of the eye contact like
nodding
because in japan they just don't want to
make eye contact they do everything to
avoid eye contact so doing that's
impossible so
every time i have to shout out i die a
little bit yeah i think my life
expectancy goes down by a few months
every time i assume
and especially if it fails yeah but then
have you ever had the the pity one where
i've said it like suma said and then
they won't ignore me but one of the
customers will have heard me
yeah and he'll go like so am i saying
and they like point at me
you want your attention
but anyway back to matsuya the best
place in japan
you basically can get like a banger of a
meal that fills you up to like the brim
for like eight bucks maybe like less if
you want to get the cheaper ones
like even less like there's a the set i
go for it's like you get this like oh
it's amazing this grilled ginger pork
and like rice you get a potato salad you
got a ton judo which is like miso soup
with extra [ __ ] in it yeah it's amazing
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] yeah
but like you can get like a regular like
beef ball with all of that for like 600
yeah like like no if you want to go ham
you can get it and like you can like
like less than 10 bucks
you can like double that [ __ ] up as
well for like an additional like two
bucks and it's like a whole pig
it's like amazing i love it like every
time i come in like [ __ ] connor's coming
in get to get the whole pig carcass out
like because i'm like max everything
because i'm like i want
meat and rice i'm there it's so good
and you'll see you get these like
pathetic little bowl sizes like what am
i going to do
no i like it okay okay are good i just
think manchester is like the best
oh yeah yeah yeah but like you could but
that's because you don't order like what
they specialize in no
you get like the side menu [ __ ] right
yeah i mean yeah i guess because in
terms of like actual like beef balls
like udons like i i reckon
yoshinoya have it better than matsuya
man just saying
we're gonna we're gonna make a [ __ ]
japanese fast food tier list here
this is the best one yeah i remember
this one time um
i i went to this very like local place
with sydney because this was when we
were staying outside of japan
no not not outside outside of tokyo yeah
so it's a bit more in the countryside
um so we went in this like what we were
craving ramen so we were looking for
like a
like a local ramen place and we go to
this place um obviously
neither of us can you know speak
japanese or read it too well
so we go to this place and the entire
menu
is hand written in kanji oh yeah
no but like we had to kind of try to
figure out what everything is
and so we we we go we we pick
something that's you know looks
reasonable because we
we were looking at the price and the
price was about 1300 yen which is about
13 bucks
forgetting that in japan like ramen is
cheap
in japan it's super super cheap and we
were ordering something that was like
13 bucks when he should have in the
middle of nowhere yeah in the middle of
nowhere should
be like seven eight hundred yeah when it
should be about seven or eight hundred
yen
um and we forgot that and i remember
we we ordered it and the waiter just
looks to us and i think he was asking
are you sure he was are you sure you
want this you want this one
two of them and we were like you should
have known that that yeah
yeah did we just want some it was like
we just won ramen yeah we want it
and so he he goes back he says something
to he says something to the
chef and the chef's eyes just goes
okay oh
you you seriously like seriously their
keys out and unlock the safe
so what comes out is they bring us this
like extra large
ramen and then with it was just this
extra large beef bowl
and then he brings out one of them puts
it in front of me and i just think
i've made a massive mistake i look at
sydney sydney's just staring at this
ball being like that
cindy seems like we ordered two of those
two to one each
because it would be impossible for one
of us to finish this let alone
uh uh two of us finishing both of them
yeah and
so so we bring it out and he brings he
brings it over to sydney and i don't
know what the etiquette is if you don't
finish your food
but we we [ __ ] try to devour as much
as we can we don't even get through half
of it
we feel we feel so [ __ ] bad
we were getting the bill it was the most
shameful bill of all time
so you're sure about that are you sure
okay okay [ __ ]
we didn't even make a [ __ ] dent in
this oh my god
i've never experienced that because like
i would rather like like behead myself
than leave food in a japanese place i
don't know why i'm so scared of it
like one time in matsuya funny enough i
accidentally ordered two of like the
double
l size sets right which is like way too
much fruit it's like i think it's near 4
000 calories
like it is like a mountain of rice and
and i don't know how i actually did this
i should have realized
how much i paid and it came and i was
like [ __ ]
i wasn't even that hungry i was like
[ __ ] so i
i like forced this inside of me yeah
i was like when i got home i threw up
but like
in the restaurant i was like if you
could imagine like
a dude literally like if his esophagus
was full i was literally like
like trying to be so soup to like push
it down you know what i mean i was like
give me more water i need to push this
[ __ ] down with water
it was it was horrible i thought i was
going to die you must have been looking
at me like me
crying in a mazia like why is he why is
he still eating you that's just like the
most
british thing i've ever heard would
rather throw up from eating too much
food and feel the shame of leaving food
i'd rather throw up in like an alleyway
than like
like order way too much clearly and then
you have to give them it back and be
like throw it away yeah yeah
like yeah okay was it very unhealthy and
extremely questionable but yeah but
you know sometimes you have to make a
decision but i got the respect from
those martials but when i said
i [ __ ] meant that
i'm like walking out like
like my bowls stacked on top of each
other i've never eaten that much food in
my life
i tell you the one place i don't feel
shameful for leaving food on the plate
though and that's whenever i go to
america
and oh yeah just witness the food sizes
there for
everything like i had that in [ __ ]
chicago when i was at a conal delete i'm
sure i'm sure it's no surprise to
americans that they're food portions
yeah and i'm just like i had that in
chicago when i ordered deep dish pizza
for the first time and like
because we had never ordered it right
most of us never ordered it we were like
oh yeah it's just the same as a regular
people
so it's like what seven of us there yeah
we'll get five deep dish pizzas
it looks awful am i crazy does it look
it does it taste terrible
it tastes good but it tastes great for
the first slice yeah but one slice
is like eating a whole pizza basically
because it's it's literally just
a a whole pizza just stacked on top of
one slice
i've had like the like kind of deep ones
yeah not like
there where it looks oh no we have the
[ __ ] dude like it's like a it's
basically a basin for the sauce right
like it's
like it's a pizza lasagna that's what it
is but like at that point it's like the
whole
the best part of the pizza is the
synergy between
the synergy what are you talking
about as well bro the the way the bread
the cheese and the sauce is like the
perfect amount
you get the best bite if there was one
too many of those
[ __ ] pizza theologists right here i'm
telling you man like you
if there's too much sauce yeah you've
got to drink the pizza what's up with
that i like the saucy pizzas though yeah
yeah no no like the extra sauce
pizzas but i will admit that that deep
dish was like
damn like could you put a straw in it
and drink it probably
that's that's true i mean it goes in
layers like i didn't realize why so many
americans called pizza's pies yeah until
until i had a deep dish pizza and i was
like
oh this is this is a [ __ ] part this
is a pizza
is that where it came from yeah i think
so i'm not sure but
it it i was definitely eating a pie that
was
shaped like a shaped like a flavored pie
yeah exactly
pretty much exactly but i remember as
well like when i went to texas for the
first time and went to like i don't know
what the italian restaurant was but it
was like a big italian restaurant and
like
portion sizes in america no
portion sizes in america are already big
right yeah but in texas
it's like hold my beer yeah levels of
[ __ ] food right so we went to this
italian restaurant and it was uh it was
misty's birthday
yeah so we went to an italian restaurant
and we were like getting all this food
and you know normally when you go to an
italian restaurant anywhere
right it's like you order like one bowl
of pasta each right like whatever you
want
maybe share it around or whatever no in
in this italian restaurant it's like
one dish of pasta is like
can feed like an ethiopian family for
like a year like
it's it is an insane it's like too much
pasta yeah
and we thought that was already
ridiculous like we couldn't even finish
that [ __ ] but then
we wanted to order a cake right and we
saw oh they sell tiramisu here
and misty's like yeah i want a tiramisu
and normally when you order cake
at a restaurant it's like one slice
right yeah no they brought out the whole
[ __ ] cake it was like it was like it
was legitimately like
this big this bigger like this deep how
much was it
it's like 20 bucks what the [ __ ] it was
like i was just like
i think we ordered wrong and they were
like no there's only one tiramisu on the
menu
so it must mean this ordering okay
that's like just like
the only option of anything is a crate
of it yeah yeah i just want a bit of it
like and i'm just like and i thought
like you know oh maybe it's like a
little bit
maybe it's like a really fancy tiramisu
right because of the price but no i
wasn't expecting like [ __ ]
grandmother like bust into the [ __ ]
restaurant just be like here you go
sometimes when i'm with americans in
america and they're like yeah that place
is way too expensive you get ripped off
and i'm like bro i got like
like enough to feed my whole family in
my head i'm like no you didn't get
ripped
you've been there you've been to france
bro you get like one string of pasta and
sauce and they charge you
twenty dollars for that [ __ ] would you
like six snails for 20 euros
yeah like i'm like in europe like it's
you don't get that for that much
it's rare like i mean to me yeah la was
super expensive but i always got a [ __ ]
ton of food so i was like
yeah yeah exactly it's just i remember
having to learn the hard way that you
just never order appetizers
when you go to an american restaurant
because there's been a meal
yeah yeah because that's why you call it
appetizers
when it's like as big as the main course
i don't get it
like in every every other part of the
world you would happen you have like a
three-course meal sometimes you know if
you're feeling frisky in america you
order one thing off the menu
and that one thing can feed a [ __ ]
family for a week one thing i could
never [ __ ] believe was the concept of
bottomless fries
at a fast food restaurant bottomless
everything bottomless everything like
already like free refills was like a
whoa at concept because in australia
there's no [ __ ] store yeah but
i was like oh it's free refills and
bottomless fries i'm like
what is this what is bottomless i just
realized episode is like british and
australian people discover america
yeah what is what's up with all of this
stuff because i was so used to ordering
like a large drink at like a cinema
right like in australia because
you know you could actually finish it a
large drink
in the [ __ ] american cinemas like
they might they might as well have just
given you like
four liters of coke right you just like
blew my mind i have nothing i found out
in the cinemas in america
you can refill your popcorn in some of
that yeah yeah yeah i'm like what
no why is this allowed like i was like
why did i buy the launch then if i could
just refill it yeah okay here's the
concept i never understood right like
you can order you go to any restaurant
right usually it's free refills right
yeah this is the drink machine yeah yeah
but there's small medium and large sized
cups why would you not just get this
why would you not just get a small cup
and then i asked aki and she's like oh
some people are just too lazy to get up
to get a refill
what and i'm just like are you it's like
it's like 20 cents extra dude like are
you really that lazy
like you just be like yeah i'll pay a
little bit extra so i can sit
for longer all americans are watching
this they're like is this uh
do you agree with the points that we're
making are you frustrated that's what
i've heard from another american
and i've heard from multiple americans i
i don't get buttered popcorn
i don't think it tastes good i don't i
just don't eat while i go to the cinemas
don't it's like it's like i have to eat
i maybe get like a like a packet of
candy or something or whatever but like
i never get popcorn i need popcorn when
i go to the cinema all right
i don't want to go i'm i'm the guy who
never actively goes out and buys popcorn
but when someone like offers it i'm like
okay let me just chow down
in my head it's like it's not the cinema
experience unless i get popcorn
and that's probably because they've
conditioned me to think that way right
but i mean i like i mean do you watch a
movie at home and do you have to have
popcorn
no no no so why do you have to have why
because i'm going there
it's an experience i need to have the
popcorn maybe i don't know i think i've
just been conditioned from australia
because popcorn and australian symptoms
were
stupidly expensive i was in the uk yeah
right
and it's like and as like a high school
student it's like you kind of yeah high
school i couldn't and i think because
maybe
my parents never ever wanted to buy it
yeah right because like
you'd almost be paying a [ __ ]
mortgage to get like this popcorn and
drink
something like 10 pounds in the uk which
is like nearly like what like 14
yeah or something like that which is way
more than in america right yeah like a
large popcorn in australian cinemas
usually cost more than the actual ticket
to go watch the movie
yeah yeah i'm just like why i'll just go
down to the [ __ ] supermarket
like blow and just sneak [ __ ] in and
someone said you know it just doesn't
taste as good
i don't know man when you bring your own
[ __ ] in it tastes kind of like flat
you know i'm sorry we peasants won't
understand
you peasants wouldn't get it as a
wealthy 1800s victorian lord of the land
i would say but no like
in america did you ever go to an
american cinema yeah i did where where
they would have like
so i went to a cinema in wisconsin and
they would just have these butter
machines where you could just
basically press it i was so confused
like poor just
like as much butter as you can on the
pop we had that we in vegas we had one
that had butter but also lard
and i'm just like yeah a lot like
just pure fat yeah mainly is this a
thing yeah
they put never speak i see i saw it it
was in vegas and like another state
you just want to put lard on it because
it makes it like extra greasy
americans this is true what is this yes
it is is this true
no no no in i saw it in another state
too like i i don't think it's common
because i only saw it like
very very rarely yeah but it was like
some kind of like lardy like fatty
substance that was sitting next to the
butter i'm like
is butter not fat enough for you that
you need extra fat
and extra grease on your popcorn i just
i remember like i picked it up and i was
like
oh my hands are oily yeah my hands
shouldn't be oily
it was like touching the back of like an
oven right it was just gross
it was like like the deep fried oil [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ]
i ruined my whole popcorn i put that
[ __ ] on because everyone was doing it
yeah
it must taste good and it's [ __ ]
horrible as well like you can't put that
[ __ ] on your lap because then the grease
starts to like seep through the bottom
of the bottle
okay well you're like well like this
well while we're ranting about american
things
okay american cheese sauce we're gonna
lose all our
what okay what is american spring
what is american spree geez i i i'm just
there's
there's some things i don't understand
about america and then there's the spray
cheese
that americans apparently love i i
always thought the spray cheese [ __ ] was
just like [ __ ] you'd see in the movies
and then i went to a walmart for the
first time and i saw it i'm like it
can't be but they're always like they're
always like no it tastes amazing on
cheez-its that's what they always say
yeah it should never be in a can yeah or
when they i remember
outside of staying at someone's house in
america and they were like do you want a
grilled cheese
i was like i love a grilled cheese yeah
and then they gave it to me and i'm like
you you put the plastic [ __ ] on yeah
like you put the cheese singles
yeah yeah that's cheese i'm like that's
not cheese look on the back it's four
percent cheese maximum i guarantee it
that's not cheese yeah like just because
it says cheese flavoring it doesn't mean
it's cheese
i went to the supermarket and there was
like a kilogram of cheddar for like
two dollars yeah yeah yeah you you have
proper cheese
why not use it they're like put it on
your nachos like they were like it's too
it's i'm too lazy to cut it i think they
told me yeah
it's get a knife what do you mean it's
too late
buy utensils i literally would like cut
that [ __ ] like
and grab the block out of the peel the
wrapper and just cut it like that yeah
yeah
i wouldn't even like a normal human
being like why are you making this
difficult
i'm gonna explain because i because i
asked him because i asked one of my
american friends when i saw it at the
time
i was like what do you put this on like
like what what
because this is the only thing that i
can i i'll let you do it no no what was
i i was like what is that like no
what it doesn't even touch my bug yeah
no it's not gonna happen i don't want it
but i'll take it on a burger
no i won't even take it on a burger dude
mcdonald's
it's all i never get anything cheesy at
danny's mcdonald's in america
i don't give a [ __ ] on burgers burgers
is fine i'm used to that but like i was
like what do you put this
spray cheese on and they were like oh we
don't put it on anything we just go like
this and put it in our mouth i'm just
like you are an absolute
monkey that's right you know like we got
a lot of comments that were like why
does conor think americans are like
another species
it's because you are there's so many
things
to me that is like a british person i'm
just so baffled by when americans
explain it to me
and yeah there's just so many things i'm
just like what america
we're gonna offend so many people with
this [ __ ] america is another
i love americans but there's just like
just general life stuff there's like
what
what every time i go to america i'm like
this is another planet like
i i can't relate to these okay on a side
note there's also so many [ __ ] things
i love about america yeah oh yeah
of course of course like i'm not gonna
be like i'm never gonna go back to
america of course i love america
i think i've never had like met
friendlier people than in america like
i love the uk it's my home but damn are
people [ __ ] depressed oh yeah yeah
like
dude i get the best elevator experience
in america no exactly you feel
so [ __ ] happy right you're talking to
americans and i'm like
man maybe maybe they're on to something
yeah like and like we clown on their
food but damn
man some places they give you some
[ __ ] amazing oh dude like i'll clan
on their food but if
someone was like you want a philly
cheesesteak i'm like hell yeah
cheesesteak you want to go chick-fil-a
yeah yeah of course i do like five guys
of course
oh my god five guys bro i [ __ ] love
five guys we all got five destroying my
body has never felt so
[ __ ] good five guys man
the best ex the best way to experience
five guys is that like three a.m
you're absolutely hammered from the
booze and you're like i need something
in my stomach
oh five guys i really go to five guys
you got the
greasiest [ __ ] burger and while
you're eating it it's like
it's it's it's like cajun fries man it's
the cajun cajun fries as well
it's cajun fries but also the burger
just the combination of those two is
like the best [ __ ] thing in the world
but i've never experienced like life and
death at the same time while eating
something you know what i mean it's like
it's like experience i'm like oh god i
feel i'm so glad i'm alive but then the
moment it goes down myself because i'm
like [ __ ] i want to die right now holy
[ __ ]
i really want to do a like a road trip
around the u.s because like it's yeah it
seems like there's so many like
diverse cultures and cool [ __ ] they get
up to every time i go to a new state i
always go
i always try and go to like a fast food
chain that's like specific to
that state just because it's so
different like i know you guys don't
like in and out but i [ __ ] love it
now
it's not that i don't like it i just
think it's a bit overrated i've never
had it it's a bit overhyped but
it's just like it's good it's not
something like froth dude i [ __ ] over
i love it dude whenever like i go to la
and if evan picks me up i'm like evan
let's go in now right now i want to go
in and out right now you know what's a
really good burger chain in texas they
have this baby chain called whataburger
yeah they've oh i've heard about that
they have it in california as well
yeah but it was like originally like
whataburger is like [ __ ] awesome like
the spicy sauce that they have is
so good yeah like i feel like i'm dying
but every single day
i feel so happy with the food i've eaten
in america yeah but then i guess
that would wear off if i lived there
every day i think so yeah maybe
i i just feel so happy in the u.s i'm
like the food's amazing everyone's so
kind
the hotels are so spacious in london you
pay like 200
for like a closet yeah if you're lucky
if you're if you're lucky
you might have your own toilet like the
hotel game in england is just weak
it's the shittest thing on earth it's
like the business hotels here right it's
like would you like a bed and a hallway
200 please if you want a semi-competent
hotel in london you've got to pay like
300 pounds or maybe 200 pounds if you
get lucky and find a good one but in
america
every single hotel i've been to except
i've never been to a motel so i don't
[ __ ] with those
yeah because that's why people die in
films
i've had an amazing hotel experience
that's why fugitives like hide out right
yeah everything every single thing
that's bad happens near a motel so i've
just
my brain has been taught don't go to a
motel calling a motel a hotel is the
equivalent of calling mcdonald's a
restaurant right it's like
it's like no it's not i remember i was
gonna i was gonna get a motel for like
my first day x and then the reviews were
like
uh someone was shot outside my room and
there was there was cockroaches
uh two stars i'm like two stars i'm like
how many people had to die for to be one
star
like that was like the one the only
reason why it's a two star is because
i didn't die yeah cockroaches didn't eat
me alive in my sleep so
because i just feel like parts of l.a
just feel like another world
yeah it is especially someone somewhere
downtown l.a i remember the first
morning i woke up in like a hotel in l.a
like it was the hotel it was one of
those alarm clocks that like the radio
starts to play
the moment the light comes the you know
sun comes up
and all i heard was like it's a lovely
morning here in los angeles three people
got shot last night
have a good day it's weird like cool
it's weird because when you listen to
the radio you're like whoa
[ __ ] gta was like super accurate like
whoa this sounds exactly like gta when i
listen to the radio in like
america yeah legitimate i was like
afterwards like after he said like have
a good day i was just waiting for like
the title screen music to just stop
playing
she was like i remember my first day um
in la oh like the first time i went to
la was for anime expo
i remember we were staying in this
airbnb in downtown l.a i remember the
first day we went to
get a taxi to the convention center me
and sydney were just waiting for our
uber
outside and then this homeless guy tries
to start tries to start talking about
this uh
uh tries to start talking to us i don't
i don't know what it is about homeless
guys not just in l.a just in general
they just
they speak another language like you you
you can't understand what's being in
tongues this is this is what
is this what english english uh english
sounds like to non-english people
that's that's the kind of language that
they speak yeah and we're like
sorry you know we're we're we're like
going off somewhere
so he he walks off like about five
minutes past us
whips his dick out and just starts
peeing i'm like hell yeah what is going
on here
america what is this what is happening i
i kind of had like a similar experience
uh the first time i went to new york and
uh
i remember i was just walking down i
think it was fourth street or somewhere
like one of the big manhattan roads
yeah and i was just like walking around
being like oh cool like you know this
like every gangster movie like
scenery i'm like this is [ __ ] awesome
and this woman just like taps me on the
shoulder
and i'm like yes can i help you and
she's like did you know that
jesus reincarnated in career in the
1940s
like go on i love it when those people
talk
and i just let her talk and she was just
going on i was like i didn't even know
because she sounded so sophisticated but
the [ __ ] that was coming out of her
mouth was like oh you've done
a lot of drops yeah so i was just really
like enthralled i'm like
wow is this like a is this like a normal
currency like i never get bored here if
this happens
i had something like that in japan yeah
like four months
ago right i was walking i had my
headphones on i was going to the gym i
clearly looked like i was going to go
exercise
yeah yes and then i like heard something
i said someone's saying hello
hello and i'm like my brain clicked i'm
like wait no one would say hello
normally
yeah it's at least three like 70 year
old women
yeah and they're like i like are you
english are you english i'm like yeah
yeah yeah what's up
what can i do for you and they like
start showing me papers and it's like
poorly translated english that's like
some monk died or something and they
they were like let's go pray let's go
pray i'm like
i'm going gym i'm gonna get my games
like they're like no no come come to the
the park near us like
come to the park we'll go and pray we'll
go and pray they're really nice about it
but i was like
bro no i said i'm i'm going yeah yeah
yeah to the gym
let me go to the gym they're like no no
we must pray now we just pray now
are you serious yeah yeah and then they
were like what do you do for work and i
was like oh yeah i do like
like voice acting [ __ ] yeah youtube and
they were like oh cool
let's go pray let's go pray let's go
pray
and then like they just kept asking me
like weird questions and every single
time i'd say anything they're like oh
cool
let's go pray let's go pray and i'm like
no
that's how cults start yeah they're like
four foot and i'm like get away from me
back off peasants i'm going to the gym i
won't hear any of this
and and i have the thing it was sound
about like a warlord or something
and how he died for mount fuji and some
[ __ ] and i was like what the [ __ ]
we live nowhere near melbourne yeah yeah
i was so confused
why do you want me to pray and there's
like everyone will be praying
in this park everyone will be praying
there we will help you pray
i'm like what the [ __ ] who's everybody i
was so confused it was japan right
i just never experienced anything like
this in japan people don't approach you
i mean i
experienced like [ __ ] like that in like
shinjuku like shibuya
it was like right outside my house so i
was like really worried that they like
knew where i lived
it was literally like right outside my
door i'm like they're like where do you
live show us where you live they kept
asking me
i'm like that's like the one the one
foreigner in the area as well instantly
recognized yeah yeah yeah
there's no foreigners where i live so
like they're like yeah where do you live
where do you live and i'm like thinking
like my house is right behind me i'm
like
over there yeah i'm like over there over
there
they kept asking me to pray i was like
leave me alone and when i kept walking
away they kept following me
to the [ __ ] gym and then i went in
the gym and they finally left me alone
because they also couldn't get in
because
yeah yeah yeah yeah once they just like
yeah let's practice
let's pray i'm like you know what fine
i'll pray if you spot me come on
jesus christ i was like genuinely
creeped out because i was worried that
when i went in the gym that they were
going to stay there
yeah until i was done yeah i was like
why me is it because i'm white
like leave me alone it's because you're
finally the minority
what did i do leave me alone bro that
was the yeah that was like
way creepier than any like uh l.a
actually
no that's pretty no it's it's ldla
stuff's pretty creepy i mean
it's just because i'm so as someone from
england
and basically you know all of europe and
also asia
it's pretty safe to walk around here
yeah and anywhere you you
try to you if you need to go home or
walk to a new bar you just
walk there yeah in america if you go you
can be at the like the nicest bar
and one block away you can get shot or
something if you just take a wrong turn
that's what it is i was so scared
walking in san francisco at like 1am i
was like oh my god i'm gonna die
i'm gonna die i'm texting my friends
being like you can have my stuff bro
i'll take my youtube channel like it's
all over
here's the password it's one am at san
fran bro i'm dead yeah
yeah and i remember it was i think it
was ax two years ago where we
we had a hotel suite and we also had an
airbnb yeah and it was only like five
minutes walk away from each other oh my
god but
the airbnb was so scary it was wasn't it
it was a [ __ ]
great airbnb it was like the it was like
it was like the chillest airbnb we had a
[ __ ] pool table and everything yeah
but it was it just seemed like in the
dodgiest area
that was where like the homeless guy
thing happened before
yeah cause i remember i remember like we
were gonna go to your airbnb for
like a house party and you gave me the
coordinates i'm like oh it's just down
the road
so we just start walking and i'm just
like it's telling me to turn into this
alleyway
and then i'm just like nah gosh it's
[ __ ] just it just gets darker and
darker and darker
because i remember i invited john super
eye patch wolf to the party as well
and i gave him like the general area
right and he was having trouble finding
it
and um i remember trying to run out to
try and get him to
get to go come to the party yeah and he
was like down the road so all he saw
was some guy coming out in like this
dark alleyway showing
john john john and
he he just [ __ ] turns around and just
walks the other corner
i can't imagine what he was thinking i'm
out of here
not not today not today oh my god that
was weird like the homeless guy
the one i i pushed over a homeless guy
that sounds terrible i didn't fight him
i just pushed him over this sounds
terrible by the way
just going around pushing over homeless
people so like it was like 3am and i was
walking to the hotel from the airbnb and
it was already sketchy as [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah and there was like a woman
crying on the floor in a corner
and like this guy with no shirt on just
shorts
like tattoos all over he was like five
foot
like four foot ten yeah very small as
[ __ ] and he was like
malnourished he had like no teeth and he
was just screaming at this girl
like threatening her in the corner and i
was like well [ __ ] i have to like say
something
yeah and so in my awkward british self i
was like hey
um could you could you stop doing that i
think she doesn't like it it's like what
i said right yeah
he's like who the [ __ ] you think you are
man who the [ __ ] you think you're like
talking to me he's like
he's like i think he's like hispanic or
something yeah yeah and and he was like
like squaring up to me and i was like
look that man come on just leave for
alone man like she's clearly like not
wanting to talk to you yeah when i say
talk
he was just screeching at her i don't
know what happened she was yeah before
crying
and so when he comes over to me she runs
off yeah
great she's gone she's safe and then
they like
from what i can remember at the time
just a little drunk a bit
yeah he like is like this close to me
yeah
shouting in my face and i'm like okay
what's gonna happen here i'm just gonna
walk away now yeah
and so like he grabs something from his
pocket i don't know what he's gonna do
so i just push him over and run away
yeah
jesus christ cause i'm like [ __ ] i don't
know what this guy's gonna do
like i'm scared as [ __ ] i don't know
what's happening i would not have the
balls to like be like hey could you can
you stop please like
because she was like it was like no one
else around and this girl was
crying her eyes out yeah well hey hey
man
hey could you could you stop it like
basically yeah then he got really angry
at me and i was like
okay and then i thought he was gonna
like hit me or something
if i see someone reaching for that
pocket like that i'd do exactly
like he didn't swing at me or anything
but he was going for his pocket and i'm
like
i literally [ __ ] sprinted away i like
ran around the corner
in my hotel i'm like yeah
yeah and like to put this in perspective
like again our airbnb was like five
minutes away from
the intercontinental yeah or something
like some like very famous hotel
shade yeah so you just don't get
something like this here
or like in europe so we we are just not
used to this that you have to
literally take you literally drive five
minutes down the road not even five
minutes down the road because it's a
five minute walk yeah just because this
this is the [ __ ] that happens
that can happen in between yeah i
learned my lesson just at that time just
probably not walking around
yeah don't intervene if you're not
willing to push someone over i guess
i don't really know i didn't feel great
about pushing him over because he was
way smaller than me
yeah but like i don't know i mean but if
you never know if he was going to like
just pull out a gun
the guy clearly was on something yeah he
was
out of it like spawning nonsense like he
wasn't talking english like i mean he
was trying to but
you know i mean i don't know what he was
on but it was scary it's terrifying yeah
anyway is there anything you want to
talk about or is that where we should be
i'm not trying to demonize homeless
people i think most of them are super
chill and really nice i just had there's
one or two interactions just get the
[ __ ] out of me yeah
just want to make that out there before
people in case there are any homeless
people
watching yeah i think he's cool with you
guys that's all right
also any americans as well oh yeah yeah
we we say all this [ __ ] about americans
in america but like
we we're okay with you guys this is just
the culture shock that we get
whenever
we just have a lot of great stories to
tell whenever we go there so
something happens man something always
happens something always happens
when we get to the convention episodes
that's when the real oh that's when the
real stories come
coming yeah definitely in the meantime
though thank you to all the patrons for
this episode as you can see if you like
your name in on the screen right now
then uh feel free to go over to our
patreon if you want to support us look
at all these beautiful names all these
beautiful look at this look at this guy
look at this this this guy's beautiful i
like that guy
look at all these people that don't [ __ ]
in pumpkin really proud of all you guys
really really yeah if you don't [ __ ] in
mailboxes then
consider signing up someone's like damn
it i guess i have to get
because i can't install now if anyone
else has a poop story in universe no no
no no no no if you have a boob store in
university feel free to leave it on the
subreddit
we'd love to hear it and also follow us
on twitter as well yeah go follow
twitters
twitches youtube all that good [ __ ] oh
it's all in the description
we've been the the neanderthals um
i'm a changed man all right
you